esta noche
un fuerte seguidor de la nominación
presidencial de donald trump en 2016 la
lealtad de michael flynn fue
recompensada al recibir el perdón del
presidente de trump el general retirado
fue nombrado oficial de seguridad
nacional pocos días después de la
elección de chong aunque este cargo sólo
le duró un mes tras su despido
quinn admitió haberle mentido al fbi y
durante la investigación sobre presunta
interferencia rusa en las elecciones de
2016 una declaración que el ex asesor
intentó retirar a principios de este año
el miércoles
donald trump absorbió al hombre de 61
años y lo hizo público en twitter donde
lo felicito a él ya su familia el
general retirado respondió a los tuits
del presidente con una bandera de eeuu y
un versículo de la biblia
ya había sugerido en varias ocasiones
que podía perdonar fue lo que le sucedió
al general flynn nunca debe ocurrir de
nuevo en nuestro país
él fue perseguido y otra gente también
lo ha sido seguir este acto de clemencia
archivó al caso en contra de michael
frayn es el segundo conocido de hecho
han juzgado durante la trama rusa en ser
perdonado el primero fue el bayern
quien fue encontrado culpable de
obstrucción a la justicia de mentirle al
congreso y de intimidación a testigos
seguramente esta absolución defina no
sea la última del presidente son antes
de marcharse de la casa blanca